remember
right good morning everybody and uh
welcome to the meeting the ordinance
committee on tuesday of october
um before we start i'd like to welcome
cancer rose lock and capture philip
pennington to the community
and thank you very much everybody
apologize last time i'm sure if you're
not making it
you're here now and that's the main
thing
[Music]
right so first of all um
i will take the apologies for absence as
a formality
thank you very much
the minutes
of the meeting held on the 27th of july
pages 4 to 11.
i'll just do a quick page turner which
is four
five
six
seven
eight
nine
10
and finally page 11.
i'm happy to propose from the chair
to accept these minutes so
thank you thank you dad
if we take a vote on that please all
those in favor
all those against
and
any abstentions
we move on to item four declarations of
interest members with interest should
refer to the agenda items describe the
nature of their interest when the item
is considered
chair missed action
take your pardon action list on page 12
but there are no actions
[Music]
i was trying to save time there it cost
me time
right okay
um
item five agreements of agenda items
part one and two
we do have a part two item so we will
have a vote now for agreement to go into
part two i should propose we're going to
part two at the appropriate time
the agreement with the agenda items
that's right yes so with just agreement
with the gender items
part one and part two at the moment we
will take the appropriate vote later on
we'll take the vote now to
definitely test it yeah that's right i
propose seconds
urgent matters brought forward with the
mission of the chair i have none this
morning
so go to item seven audit reports issue
to date pages 13 to 18
and
from the devon audit partnership
manager and the first item up is the
cemeteries report
[Music]
he's trying to join us to speak with his
brother
right we have a problem
with the
officer trying to join us virtually this
morning
so paul middlemast cannot join us
i should be here for bradford
the debtors report
if we move on to that if i defer the
first one
right
the ordered
actions pages 26 and 27.
so
so our colleagues from the devon oregon
partnership issued various audit reports
and their various findings in those
reports
coming up those reports are various
actions for managers to do and agree
timetables for when the managers should
action the recommendations in the audio
report
um
tom's just going to
upload
a separate presentation
and hopefully make it a little bit
bigger but essentially there's been an
update since these papers were
circulated just over two weeks ago so if
people can look on the screen at the
moment
you'll see that there's various actions
that managers agree to most reports have
been issued during 2021
so there were 62 actions
agreed
27 and open and what that means is the
time scales are beyond this meeting so
they've given to maybe to january 2022
to bring in
action
and there's six that are red and they're
late so managers agreed to do a certain
action by a certain point in time and
that's not happening yes council
pennington yeah on them
on the ipad the exhibition renewals have
too late yes
and the ones in green are complete so as
you can see there were 62 actions that
managers agreed to and the 67
when i circulated the papers that thing
was higher and at that time said the
jump of janet williams from i don't know
it wasn't available to me to get an
update from her so i left that action as
outstanding and laid subsequently she
didn't confirm those actions that were
requested have been done completely
and then also i think there's one action
um
to do with lewin
about
the cards that not being used by people
on that one subsequently we've found an
easier solution to do that piece of work
so if you just move on to the next
screen please vomit on
and if there's any way you could make
that figure that would be really helpful
and i've got to apologize to some
because that's me making it like
so those are the remaining outstanding
actions and you'll probably be able to
be better probably if you see them in
your papers
so there's two from it regarding sort of
updating as i understand it i'm sure
james r
john could come in this is really more
about how we take payments
and the actual debt
has actually moved so that's very hand
and there's a safe update of our safe
guarding policy and stay safe when
you've got that
revised date there is in october
end of october
safeguarding sorry safeguarding
apologies by our size i can't believe
that uh the car parking was a business
plan though some phillips who's out of
state relatively new to the council
that's got quite a lot on his agenda
not least our asset through
our asset management so it isn't a
priority at the moment he's a medium
risk but he is aware that we need to
update our
our business plan for car parking as
much as anything so some plans for our
net carbon nutrients as electric
charging points
and so
revisiting signage and we're having
charges
as well
and this is more about
of internal housekeeping
um and keeping notes on the account if
you just move it to the right then so i
think the low priority
the low priority things
ever been on karina who's in charge of
business rates actual functioning other
accident brokerage is actually sick at
the moment i've not managed to get an
update from her as to where she'll be in
terms of updating the note taking
regarding our debtors so i wasn't going
to comment anymore basically with 62
actions and six of them are late and the
detail is uh provided to you and it's in
your reports as well it's just a smaller
list than it was because some things
have been updated and done since
okay
is there any
questions just really from melbourne
sorry
what term what sort of financial figure
are we talking about the debtors
in terms
the recommendations then on debtors are
i'd say housekeeping
the query in the robotic report on
debtors was regarding how we calculate
the collection rate
and actually
on our debtors the outstanding debt is
actually really relatively about the
figures and the reason being
well you say look very low the reason
do a lot of being
sundry debtors
so add up invoicing of people to say
you've knocked our wallet out of your
van
which
raised an invoice to you
a lot of our debtors system debtors go
through relates to property things like
beach huts the industrial units et
cetera where people are on payment plans
so they tie very heavily to profiter the
area where we would where we raise debt
is where we have the biggest right of
what you won't be surprised to find out
it's in relation to homelessness where
we support people with rent in advance
and deposits because that's a more
difficult debt to secure and it's also a
debts where we've probably got payment
plans over a longer period for people
i just bothered to make visually work
with some officers time chasing debts
that are unrecoverable
probably not in a large extent
um
[Music]
like i said the debt that the cash one
category of debt that's probably the
hardest to recover will be the things
that we make in respect of preventing
homelessness
the you know we don't have a debt
recovery issue with people with beaches
for example or our industrial units we
don't have
is there a plan in the long term should
that sickness instead extend in the
future so that that doesn't pass the
statutory power periods
you've got
and you've got one person that seems
like thing falls
a little bit more complicated as well
karine is based in charge of business
trains which also has the debtors under
her the debtors um
that's a vacancy at the moment we're
recruiting too
okay so you've got something in place to
to keep the system going in the long run
yeah fun yeah we effectively have a team
of people um alongside legal that will
help with cover i think
a big point and it's probably a little
bit misleading but david was just saying
in relation to karina he hasn't had an
update she would be the manager
responsible for updating the audio
reports etc but yeah behind the scenes
we've got teams of people that assist
and depending on what service area it
comes from yeah there's not always just
that
responsibility
that's one of these internal processes
is that when we raise an invoice it's
dependent on the host of companies
raising these both sufficient data and
also provides sufficient backup detail
when the invoice is queried
where it's even tolerated if that
component is a relatively small
proportion
a lot of our debts is what i'd call
routine system related debtors which
pertains to property and the rental
thereof that's that biggest component
and those processes are pretty well
defined and also the people have an
incentive to pay because otherwise so
we'll be able to talk about the
proposition so when we come back next
time these two labels will be non-late
ones i think yes
thank you
so much
okay so the no further questions on
there and we will go back to
item number seven
yeah so um
good morning to you sorry and and
apologies um so this pulled me the best
from dap apologies um for my late
arrival i was having problems uh zoom
problems so i couldn't get in but uh um
and i just like to say about the the the
the recommendations actions obviously um
it is quite important that this
committee obviously um
i suppose uh looks at um implementation
of actions
and and particularly the high and medium
ones and and as you can see david has
identified the the priority of
recommendations
but obviously it's the key part of the
role of this committee to i suppose
challenge
where actions are are overdue
particularly the higher priority ones
and and and what um
action
management has has in place really to to
come up with a revised target
um and to try to avoid um obviously some
of these these actions um and dragging
on so that that's um the point i'd like
to make about the the recommendations
um then they're not going um
back to our
the the dap report so um this is
as you know our our standard update
report
providing a summary of our work
um we have uh free audit reports in in
the update
um and as you know a summary of the
um
that there's a summary in appendix a but
you all have copies
we've sent you copies of a full audit
report as as well
um as you can see we've provided a
reasonable assurance opinion for for
debtors but then we have two limited
assurance supports for
for cemeteries and um the one on cyber
homework
and capacity
um so i'll just
give up a brief update on both of them
so
debtors so we looked at how debt
management was was handled really over
the last year we sort of thought about
well what might have been the impact
given given that resources were diverted
to managing grants and so on
um and and this did mean some reduction
in um the amount of attention um on on
monitoring debts
um or
um so so we did find that
um the amount of debt over one and two
years
did increase um slightly
um but only slightly given the reduced
resource and i think david's really
again david's really commented
on on why that might or was the case in
terms of um you know a lot of these
invoice being invoices being raised and
so on were for for rents and so on
um
in in terms of coming to a a better
figure on debt collection because again
um and this is a bit of a historical
thing about how council has collected
debt um
we have
recently been been speaking to other
finance officers about coming to a
better
calculation figure
um and we think that it does have merit
in terms of providing a better
assessment the
it's not a complete solution because it
does
consider um
um collecting debt over more than one
year so we we asked the question what
was your debt collection in year
um
and um the solution 5 it doesn't doesn't
actually do that it sort of provides
a figure of debt collected over
this year and
previous years but but it is a
is an improvement to what is currently
in place
um the next two two reports um provide a
limited so cemeteries
um obviously you're probably aware of
the issues with the ground maintenance
contract
and uh you're probably aware of that um
that the council is is preparing to
bring these in the house
um
next year
but um to to improve matters they are
undertaking more
regular meetings with a contractor to
try to improve
um
how the contract is managed
um and and also there are a couple of
issues about the it systems being being
used such as the autocad software
that means that it maintains the
cemetery plans and so on
um and also cemetery pro
which is contains burial information and
question about whether it's
effectively backed up
for instance
um
in terms of the cyber security one on
homework
security and capacity again really
important and has been over the last
year or so
um so looked at the use of council
mobiles
and
room networking technologies and so on
um and this was using a benchmark of
cyber essentials which is a centrally
provided government sort of model
on the controls that should be in place
um and as you um if you look at report
um obviously there's quite a long list
of
strengths that we
i identified um i don't want to go into
them um
and also the some weaknesses again
that's clearly sort of listed out in the
report
um
that we made
three high and
six medium recommendations
uh which uh to some extent is indicative
of the
high risk environment that that is in
place
in in this area
um but um what was encouraging is that
the um recommendations are either
going to be um implemented immediately
or or by um the first of january um of
of next year so by three months time so
that's that's really quite encouraging
um so that's that's um
the the update i was going to i provided
um so
is there any questions you want to put
to me or to david
do we have any questions
just just a comment about the cemeteries
actually i want to do complaints from
people about the state of the cemeteries
and i think that we're doing all that
here but i don't think this does just
cause distress for some of the people
who regularly visit
pay respects to one's past and
i think we need to do better um one way
or another i know this is normally
leaking but it has an effect really
in the cemeteries and i just would like
to record that comment please
yes i understand
i picked up on the fact that the service
has got uh we're talking about the
autocad software the service company has
no one trained to use this software
when this was identified
could not have been put
right straight away
well i i would personally have said so
so so yes so it is a bit of a quick win
and um
obviously quite
easy i'd have thought to identify
someone and and to do it but
at the time i'll hold it um it it hadn't
been done we would have reported it if
it had
it was brought to the attention of the
relevant officer at the time
yes no indeed yes we uh discuss and
agree our audit findings um
and agree the recommendations so um
if if you just um bear bear with me just
looking at um
the old report now about when they
intend to do it um
so the
so let's see autocad plans are updated
on an as needed basis using external cad
providers
the intention is for the council to
recruit in-house cad capability so um
i think they they view it as quite a a
technical
technical software that they need to
recruit for
which is why they can't um
implement it immediately
and as for getting the license is that
simply an application or usually
licenses are obtained
with a payment of money is that the
situation in this case
yes it would be um
again um
looking to find the
actual management response
which i can't immediately see it
yeah i can't sorry i just can't
immediately see what the uh
what the response is but i can provide
an update for the committee
to save you hang on
and then one final question are you
planning to revisit this in the near
future to see that everything is in
order as you've only given limited
assurance
yes he's a two limited report so
so so yes i think um we would need to a
a follow up on both of them
looking at the implementation dates
um
probably uh early um
in in 2022
would would be timely to confirm i mean
obviously
tracking of recommendations which is
what david is doing now is is is
important part of that process but we
need to also do a follow-up
um it's it's part of our standard policy
that we do that
thank you paul thank you thank you right
if you'd like to continue
oh sorry
sorry i didn't see him i just wanted to
say
are we still playing with the tractor
and he's not
um you know
his um contractual communications and it
said
typically for what we do so we pay them
for what the actual works they actually
undertake yeah so if they don't do the
work then we're not paying the words
to deliver okay that's good thank you
right back over to you paul
yeah so the next agenda item is on the
um
auditing governance committee
effectiveness um so that's that's page
18 onwards
um
and um so uploads an effect to the
effectiveness of the
audit committee so i'm just saying so
important that the committee review
their effectiveness um annually
um so for instance whether they are
providing sufficient challenge to um
management and and members
um sit for uh provides
a self-assessment um checklist to
support those activities
and um
we and the um
david have collaborated on a sort of
initial report
based on the checklist
if you look at the report paragraph 2
provides us for some of our
our own high level conclusions
um that the
committee generally meets the the high
standards
they also
note some recent problems
uh related to involvement and engagement
of of members
and also
notes for use of zoom meetings
and that and and the move to hybrid
meetings
um
and um it would be good to get um a
members view on on these meetings
so um
paragraph five um notes really it's for
members to discuss
and and the grievous um or what they
consider their performance against the
checklist
um and i think it's you know intended to
use this this this forum here read to do
that
so
what what i suggest is um perhaps
that we start with each section
of the checklist um and and have a
discussion about each of them and then
come to an overall sort of assessment
on on on the audit committee and
governance effectiveness
if that's okay
um so can i suggest that then we talk
about um the first section which is on
the audit committee purpose and and
governance
um
and obviously useful get your thoughts
and any uh any comments and there's a
good understanding
of the committee's purpose and role and
so on
right thank you paul i noticed that in
your paragraph you say that meetings are
effective with a good level of
discussion engaging with all the members
so yes with that
in mind
i will throw it open to um
the councillors here committee
to go through and if you would like to
talk us through
the items paul
um the first one is does the authority
have a dedicated audit committee
and yes we were established in 2010
meets regularly
two does the audit committee report
directly to full council
committee can decide to escalate issues
to full council
and the uh chair in the offices reports
take into account as and when required
um
that
we do make reports to full council
for them to monitor our effectiveness
and do the terms of reference clearly
set actually
can i just ask an example of when
something's gone with you
so i i've read that and i tried to think
of something that the productivity
actually sent from council
and i'm grateful if you could say
when
when we actually sent something truthful
in my time
i have raised things with individual
officers
and
when we had a previous and
head of paid service
in addition we have an annual report
to full
councils highlighting the work we've
done
and where we deem ourselves to be
effective
we we do
inward look
on ourselves at this meeting with this
document
and it is up to us to self-report in
some ways
okay but apart from the annual report
there is no
practical example
of this committee referring something to
full council
c yeah i was just thinking um the
data protection regulations were
referred um
2018 that was one of the big ones and
that was one that was pulled up by an
audit report that we hadn't complied
with our requirements so that that's
what i can think of
that's when i took the head of paid
service yeah and further report was done
yes and we had to report back to full
council to show that we were fully
compliant so
thank you
right
so with that item 5 does the audio
committee provide
support to the authority in meeting the
requirements of the government
we've got examples of their
the compliance um
are the arrangements of sort of you know
too much again no police do um what
about number four i mean there used to
be independent members on your committee
and i noticed there's no independent
members here at all in the present
moment and they brought more insight i
think than
most of us coasters because they have
pretty
good idea of of auditing and they were
chosen for their skills and i think
when i was last on the old committee
we had a couple of really good members
independent members
why are we not having any independent
members to support us
we have tried to recruit
and to be honest i failed
to attract interest i think paul may be
able to help we wanted to try and see if
we could group one at demon arden
partnership level and that person could
attend different meetings i'm not too
sure that's what i've progressed so i
know individually
not too distant past trying to recruit
and have not been successful
because um you know i mean apart from
about four or five group counselors i
you know on the council we've got a
really good idea of accountancy
and all this um i think the majority of
the councillors are you know
representing the community
that don't have the depth of knowledge
that really could bring insight into
where issues maybe you're rising and so
and that is where i think we need your
expert advice really just to guide us
through the process
you are very right we we did have a very
excellent member
um
ms dashworth in my time
who stood down after you've done a
certain returns
one of the problems we've got as i
understand it is
we don't have a wealth of people
who could assist if we were in one of
our sort of university towns or cities
we would have that in
that quality of person available
we did have one person we were assuming
in the end didn't go forward
to the interview stage but all we can do
is advertise and see what comes back and
we need to
appoint somebody who's appropriate with
a skill level and who can bring
something to our community
and that is why we do have a problem but
we could only keep advertising
yeah i suggest sure that any councillors
know of any individuals that we feel may
well have necessary skills as going to
the planet that's indicated to obviously
put their hands forward
because
yeah i think
that's all we can do
um the last item here is are the
arrangements to hold the committee to
account for its performance operating
satisfaction
um
and we have the answer there with the
mince of the audience governments show
that
what has been discussed and agreed you
do risk management strategies internal
control statements anti-fraud
arrangements whistleblowing strategies
[Music]
rather than go through the report
comment by comment
does anybody have any
items that they've brought forward
themselves i'm trying to encourage
discussion here um
[Music]
or paul do you want to come back on
anything
yeah so so so so thank you so um
the the
the comments raised earlier i suppose
about para point two um does the audit
committee report direct to full council
now obviously that's seen as really
important by asset for and others the
fact that this audit committee reports
directly to council but i think it's
really a fair challenge
about identifying when that actually did
occur
and something to obviously to be to
think about that it is you know
your role to i suppose to flag things um
priorities use things that to go to full
council
um
and in terms of the independent member
yeah i think we've got adap has got sort
of a bit of a standing uh agenda item
too to um take that agenda forward it's
not yet a legal requirement that um
independent members be be appointed to
audit committees
um but it um
may well be brought in and i think we
so what i i suppose i would encourage
that david and
the chairs do you you both attend the
adap
the regular that management board
meetings i suppose you can ask um which
i think the next in
next next month of energy to be held
again you can ask again that question
of of rob hutchins for the head of dapp
um to to
ask him what progress is being made but
i very much like that suggestion of
um
i do yourselves identifying um people
who who
might be interested
in in
providing knowledge and so and and then
just the last thing i'd say is obviously
we we attend these meetings that's the
internal external orders but we are also
available um for for meetings outside
this this meeting and in fact i do need
to meet more regularly with the the
chair i suppose about discussing
things outside of this meeting um to get
ourselves individuals of thoughts on the
control framework and so on
but but
moving on i mean so the second um
second area is on functions of of the
committee and again
um probably time
um doesn't allow us to go through each
one of these but um
i i suppose this is broadly asking is is
committee reviewing
all the key areas
related to uh governance and
an internal external audit and value for
money
and and risk management etc so um that
that's sort of the big the the question
about these these different areas so
again what are some members views
about about the functions of the
committee um obviously you've got you've
got the governance function but also the
audit committee function and whether
those two work together well
so i'll just leave it and to members to
comment again
any comments from
yes um
[Music]
has the committee evaluated whether and
how did that advantage the organization
and the answer is no
but the last confrontation that was
carried out was in 2016.
it was wonderful why nothing had
happened since 2016.
my understanding we have put um
consultations out to members
and the replies
we don't get a lot of feedback and i
would encourage more feedback about this
community um
[Music]
obviously investigate that and and thank
you for for raising that um that that's
understanding but um we can revise that
date if if needed
but i i think it's a very good good
point about
um
us all sort of
trying to um see what what value we we
add
um
often from an audit perspective that's
the question we we often ask ourselves
we've we've done this all day
um and we might have found a substantial
what's the point of doing it
so there's always that that challenge
whereas if it's uh princesses are
limited
opinion then it's i suppose the the
benefits are are are clearer
but um yeah i think it's a really valid
question to
keep coming up with that sort of
question on value for money
um
one that i pick up on is question 17
does the committee have good working
relationships with key people
organizations including external audit
internal audit
and the chief financial officer and it's
got an answer yes
the audit government didn't show this to
be the case but i would just like to
pick up on something at the very last
page on page 106 it says at the end of
each meeting
should it be deemed desirable members
may meet
with the
external auditors privately now before
this meeting took place historically i
used to meet
grant thornton to
[Music]
discuss matters with them
that i may wish to raise or they may
wish to raise with me prior to the
meeting you know
i might have concerns or something i
wish to challenge privately before the
meeting
i haven't had the opportunity recently
that i know kovid has played a large
part in this
but i would i would like to make it so
that i meet with the auditors before the
meeting rather than afterwards or if
that is not possible
they contact me by either
zoom or by phone
because that input builds better
relationships and a better understanding
of where we are
in the audit process and any concerns
they may have and to give adequate
reassurance to me
if i'm if i'm able to come in and
comment on that absolutely um agree with
that and i know we did initially try and
sort of get some some time set up and i
know there's been some some issues with
with the emails um emails reaching you
so absolutely we'll take that forward as
an action with you and just picking up
on paul's point really um it is quite
routine for for a number of um audit
committees that i attend for different
uh public sector bodies not just for
local government but also within the nhs
that we do arrange
private meetings which just gives you an
opportunity um as as audit committee
members to to discuss any specific
issues uh without officers um uh present
and that's not necessarily just to have
conversations behind officers back it's
really just an opportunity to support
you and and and um help sort of build
your understanding of of what the the
audit responsibilities in our audit
cycle involves etcetera so
we absolutely welcome that opportunity i
think one thing i would i would ask to
to give some consideration to is whether
it actually would be more more
worthwhile to have it as a joint
discussion with internal audits and
particularly some of the things that
we've been talking about as part of the
valley for money work which we'll come
on to as part of our own report we're
finding increasingly now that there's a
lot of overlap between
the work and coverage of internal audits
work and the scope of the work that's
now required under this much broader
assessment and the new value for money
arrangements so i'd certainly give
give chair give you the opportunity to
sort of reflect on that and take that
away but absolutely welcome
a separate conversation we would support
that okay that's good you said their
email difficulties getting in contact
with me would you like to elaborate
yes sorry so i think we wish we
originally tried to have a bit of
correspondence um back back prior to the
last audit committee um about settings
about setting some meetings up um and i
think i think we had a bit of
conversation at the last committee that
things weren't quite getting through to
you so
we'll try and sort out that sort of
email connection problem and and if
there's an alternative contact i can
manage your availability through then
that might be an alternative route to
try and get that set up so yeah
absolutely
no i welcome that thank you very much
thank you
right do we have any further comments
so i'm not exactly clear on
what the governance part of our title
and
um
i understand when supposed to make that
sure that the council is
carrying out his duties properly but
what responsibilities do we have for the
high team
i don't know absolutely nothing about
rit and the i.t security etc and i'm
wondering
right
okay
i hear what you say um
this was something that i thought might
come up
and
where we would go with
that rather than discuss it here if we
went into any depth with security issues
i'd have to go into part two
but what we can do is to speak the
appropriate officer
after the meeting at a suitable occasion
and get that reassurance for him
that we can
be happy with
rather than try and dissect it here i
haven't got the appropriate officer with
us at the moment
but i understand what you're saying the
other thing is we used to have a meeting
um
between all the audit committee chairs
and vice chairs
and any other member that wanted to
attend mr had seminars
[Music]
they haven't taken place in the last
couple of years
obviously due to kobe
but
perhaps there would be an opportunity as
we've got a fairly
new audience community with new members
coming on that we could organize some
training from
about some slides wonderful
okay so dude how's that in hand
i need to be messed up okay thank you
david
thank you i suppose the other point to
make is when you say you don't know
about it i'm i'm not actually illiterate
but the reports
that have been presented by clothes i've
never known the partnership they've
actually brought in specialists
who did that report so that report is
for you as a committee to say
well do i own you know there's issues
that they've raised that's why we had
john
and james jewell there before just in
case you had any questions on that audio
report
um did so we could at a future meeting
have say the estates manager in to
answer your questions about the cemetery
so i don't know everything about
cemeteries and how they're organized but
you know
our causes a demonic partnership will
and that's why they produce social
fortunately the user committee to
scrutinize those reports and does it do
they give you cause the concern
obviously if they give a limited
assurance essentially democratic patch
they're telling you as
members that there are some issues
within that particular section
and you know the responses that manages
whether you believe confidence in the
manager's response to it
can i can i also say on that point that
um
so it's obviously cyber is a very very
high risk area
and um you should should
you know um seek assurance from from
management but i suppose it's also your
committee role
to to say we want additional insurance
in an area so whether that means
a follow-on audit um from internal audit
or of or some other party to get that
assurance then then i've seen that that
done before in terms of so so whether
you may not have
you know the the your own sort of
technical knowledge about an area but
it's about
asking a question
okay management is telling us one thing
do we need additional assurance
to do we do do we get um additional
shirts from the other parties uh about
whether things are effective
obviously cyber security is paramount
for any council
when did we last have an audit
that was
we're happy with that
the depth that will give us assurance
essentially
that's the one that was published in the
80s today
that had a a fairly narrow focus on
obviously homeworking technology and so
on
we we have got a number of audits in in
other other councils which have got
slightly different focus
but
you know we could spend um
dozens of hours on on or days on
different elements
um we just looked at one small slice in
that audio report yeah rather than the
umbrella and that's what i'm trying to
get
we've got the draft audit plan on the
forward plan for the meeting on the 29th
of march i would probably suggest
that we probably address it on the 18th
video to do the confirmation those sort
of things
feed into
right
okay
right
just to go back to
the governance part of it
what what other things would that
include that rather than
the id would it be anything
um
it's a whole range really um from
safeguarding to ripper of
coba investigations to risk management
um most of our policies within torridge
relate to governance and making sure
areas are run as they should be
and that risks are highlighted
um you know even our employment policies
for example would fall down to
governance so it's fast um in terms of
not wanting to put you off but in terms
of what what you can obviously review
and scrutinize so
i i i can't think of one policy within
torridge that probably doesn't revert
back to governance of some some caller
i've been on like maybe two years and i
can't recall discussing anything other
than the financial well there is the
annual government statement council
which is
i mean the annual government statement
is supposed to encompass saying to
members how we do but what do you say in
council how do we check that that is
what you're doing it's about having a
statement of the governance but aren't
we there aren't we here to check that
the council is carrying that out
a lot and we haven't had any
any training on it and we haven't um
you know had any reports to us on
i know that claire i mean claire helsing
himself kept raising safeguarding
wouldn't she and she pushed that on and
until until something was done about it
but unless we she came up with that
herself in seeing her as simple again
japping something unless we see it for
ourselves
how are we supposed to check
that we are getting government properly
so most of those policies come to full
council so you call the last full
council we have the safeguarding policy
so any of our policies that we adopt
would come to capital council for review
and safeguarding is the most recent one
but obviously the constitution
which is the main form of governance
within torridge um we had you know
separate working groups on and of course
that came to paul council so all of that
is known as we can't just
put a policy in without full council
approving that policy especially if it
comes here and you've had some queries
or concerns then obviously we could do
that through this group but in your main
all of those policies whistle blowing
all of that will go to full council
before being formally adopted so that's
you you wouldn't necessarily tag it up
as governance or have a governance pedal
but it is is governance and like i said
the constitution was the the largest one
or one
amendments to officer delegations and
things like that
and and debit partnership look at
specific sectors
[Music]
all countries if we have any individual
areas of concern that we need
explore we can always go to a riverbank
house and speak with a relevant officer
you know concerned in depth to get to a
one-to-one explanation of anything that
has given us concern i think that's
probably you'll get far more information
personally than you will at any
committee that you're sitting online
any area that you know you've got a
particular concern on our
and we highlighted data protection
earlier on
and i went and saw the head paid service
at that time
raised my concerns
i wasn't satisfied and it went on to
have
an audit done on it individually
to address those issues so
that's one way of doing it as well
all of our service areas across the
council are audited um
at set intervals so those audit reports
will then come to audit and governance
and um and as paul's just said you know
the concern today is cemeteries for
example you know that's been
independently audited and it's got
limited insurance now you could have
that going on your agenda because you're
not you're not happy but if an
independent auditor is ordered a
department and they're relatively happy
or we've got substantial insurance then
i guess you know as a committee you you
would be less concerned but there there
may still be areas from that
um audit report that that is an area of
concern for members and and you can you
could bring it up so that's that's your
way of of routinely looking at stuff but
of course if there's other areas that do
concern you that they can come forward
here as well but it would all go through
full council
you know um
so
the three things that have been
highlighted
we will get a report on those next time
saying whether they
have been able to fulfill
the requirement of the audit so those
managers are tasked with actions from
those audits and and
and as paul said that those audio
reports are issued with in agreement we
always have a discussion with the
auditors in terms of whether we agree or
whether we don't agree
and and
with the cemeteries one for example
those actions have been agreed the
manager has agreed that it's not as it
should be
um and david will periodically chase
to make sure those actions are completed
by the deadline is coming
[Music]
i'm sure some of those time frames will
have passed and they should have been
completed and there'll be an update you
obviously have the right as a committee
to just call in the manager of the
service
and ask him to
go through the audio before and say how
how they're doing on yeah that's what
i'm trying to get at really and we were
talking about the effectiveness of this
community what was in the show
you asked
you know you asked
that manager too so if we said for
example that we were concerned about
housing
and because we did have an issue when i
first came on about the housing payments
being slow
i mean housing benefits yeah that has
been benefits yeah sorry um
so you're saying that the procedure
would then be
to own this committee
asked for
an order
order you agreed the mounting plant with
the definitely partnership so i'm
suggesting the next committee meeting we
certainly have started to agree
the audit plan so certain things we do
every year in the main we'll do the
creditors we do the payroll
and we do what's called the main
accounting order
and other things others have done
periodically and there's an assessment
over here so for example we did quite a
lot of changes to our car parking not
only did
long serving staff leave but we changed
how we did and crowdfunding changed to
payment by card and
changed something to do with car parking
permit so that would be something i
would put in my mind about i'd like an
audit to take place in the car parks
because i know there's been a lot of
changes
so identity but then also it could be
the concerns of members could be the one
that would be one of the driving factors
obviously there's a limited resource
from definitely the partnership in terms
of holiday days
so then that'll be the discussions that
we had
members may want to do this we've got
certain audience we really should do
every year
i mean
we did free up a little bit resolve the
hardness of the
homework and i freed up some results by
saying well we've had
the highest rate in every year for
creditors
forever basically
we will let that go for one year
because we can then pretty much ask to
look at homework if that's the reaction
to the pandemic it felt better to
focus some resources with every other
partnership there so you certainly have
hasn't committed
an input into what goes on the plan from
donald trump
high risk high priority
regularly audited
and we we can only
go for
a limited number of very minor risk
issues
and also got to bear in mind there is a
backlog isn't that paul and how are you
with the backlog
oh well we we're we're taking forward
the
the audit plan for the year and and and
progress is is is fine so um
i i think so that cyborg it won i think
we
we we started at the end of last year
but obviously now completed it in this
year
i i i would say in terms of aggression
about governance so every audit
of the of the area that we audit we we
look at risk management controls and and
governance so governance is a wide
subject as you can imagine it includes
you know other senior managers do they
have
targets and priorities and performance
management and
core documents underpinning and and do
they comply with legislation
and so on how is reporting at the chain
and and so on so that's one of the key
things that we look at governance but
we we also um
if we ask to do we also undertake audits
of of a more governance nature so
in another
council i'm doing an audit on corporate
governance
about how they comply with the cipher
code on governance which cause your own
government statement annual dump
statement talks about
um as as well as more standard things
like corporate plan and performance
management so you know we can do more
specific
um audits on governance if we're asked
to do that although as we we've said you
know there's only
a limited number of days um
and there needs to be some
prioritization
of our work
does that give you
does that address your concerns yeah
i'll ask you a question i'm just
concerned that we're not most effective
for me
i mean prior to the new members there
weren't many people who spoke up
and
we're not experts on all these things
and then we're not a decision-making
really but i mean when the treasury
report came up i didn't know it had gone
to cnr i sometimes feel that um
things have gone to other community
where you have gone to communities and i
don't know about it you could say that's
my fault for not always reading all the
agendas all the wikis but sometimes it's
a little bit difficult to cover
everything when you've got oh yeah i've
got three communities and a four council
um
they're quite long agendas the audit and
the planning
so i know always and i have problems
with my life i don't always see
the items that are relevant to the
governance of the
things that um
you know concern me
and
we are
a scrutiny committee yeah
with
everything to look at
in various guises and we're very lucky
to have
to make a very personal point actually
the lack of questions that i
raised should not be taken as in any
form a lack of engagement would be the
lack of understanding
um seems to be implied
by the report by other members maybe
but i um
i think um
the
it shouldn't be taken as a lack of
understanding i i've i've been around
the block and i have every faith i'm
impressed continually impressed with
both the internal and external auditing
that takes place on all matters and i'm
particularly impressed by the officers
that this council has if i had any
concerns i would raise
no
be assured about that
thank you very much kid
i'm sure the officers are very
appreciative of that
we have gone through a very major crisis
in the last
year
and we've come out with blind colors no
question about it
um
this report is for limiting it's okay
yeah no just three points really uh
following all from uh coachella's point
about the um
you know the expertise of all the
recipes i mean we have brad poulton you
know who give us the financial side of
things but picking up on the um
digital and computerization i mean it
does concern me immensely the risks in
the modern day society when i hear
going on
um everybody is vulnerable i mean even
the most intelligent neighbor of the
people and i just wonder given the
importance whether we did not have to
have a recommendation that we have some
form
of outside order of our it procedures
i i think first we need the
understanding before we start
commissioning audit and that's where
perhaps with training and we go that's
what a democrat department should do
okay so
they don't send a to do with the
subsequent interject right they're not
sending somebody like me an accountant
to do an order
they're attending a night specialist who
does the audit of the it so they have
very special skills like identifying
risks to organization
i'll let paul speak to the democratic
party that's probably one of the reasons
you have a democratic partnership out of
having an internal
artifact got an internal department
generally the auditors of a financial
background yes and you go into areas
such as planning
um maybe the harder with health and
safety in areas like rit where you're
going into outside the internal auditor
wouldn't have that skill set and you'd
probably have to commission experts from
outside so paul can inject interjects we
want but the person i understand who did
the itr has its related skills rather
than just a pure financial
yeah so so can i just put in that um i
commented earlier that um
it was assessments again against the
cyber security
framework uh issued by the cabinet
office
so um yes the authors um that that we
used uh you know that that's what they
do they audit um cyber and i.t so
they're very specialists at the same
time
the the the audit was looking was
benchmarking against those sort of core
controls so it's very
easy to say this is standard of that the
government has told us we need to meet
um and and and so it's sort of well visa
these are the
controls that need to be in in place
and so that's what i'd point out
basically we have to rely on the experts
to report to us
that they can give assurance
and and sorry the second point is that
your it's area will also be subject to
independent checks
um whether annual annual checks
um from from outside bodies as as well
so um there might be subject to
penetration testing once a year
um
it might be interesting to to to get a
sort of list of from your it about the
the external checks that they're
testing the subject to
to white insecurity my take on that is
if anyone they've hacked into the white
house
so minnows like us
absolutely we have to this is the answer
that's right we'll follow just off of
that comment i mean we have to show due
diligence we've asked the questions that
we put protections in place from our iq
systems and when it does go wrong we can
show that we've taken the steps to try
and we've challenged we've challenged
and that is really important this
committee is all about challenges and
getting that assurance that's right yeah
right can i just go on to to one other
is the conflict between 12 and 17 in the
report here
which is um
separation from the executive first
bullet point from 12
and 17 a good working relationship now
then i spent the last 12 months watching
jeremy hunt chair of the health and
select committee real mad hancock about
the culver situation and i've laughed
because
you know jeremy hunt is his uh the
secretary of health and he laid the
foundations from hancock to um
let's say
his performance wasn't the best and um
he you know came over the situation
pretty poorly at the end of the day but
not linked to the way that government is
done
and there is a
real feeling in central government at
the moment that auditing and questions
being asked are being brushed under the
table and it is an ideology that's
coming through again and again and again
on all levels of government and how do
you protect the separation from the
executive when you have a good working
relationship and they will do it as
chair you say you have meetings outside
but how do you then
justify that you are then operating
separately
um from the executive can you answer
that one as chair i'm sorry to pick on
the spot but it does interest me
immensely
this narrow line between
you know holding people and being
separate but having a good working
relationship
right i am not frightened to ask him
questions
and i think the members
the officers to the left of me know that
i just don't take the first answer given
to me
i can be a little terrier on things
i would um
i keep referring to it but data
protection is one of the key issues i
i was not happy with the first or second
answer
and delve down deeper and had a report
i will bring to the attention of members
where i feel i have concerns
make no mistake so there came down an
issue of protecting the organization
or asking the correct question
which side of the coin would you for
you certainly asked the correct question
in private
you report to members right you have
concerns you wouldn't ask it and open
i would address my concerns initially to
the leader
if i wasn't happy with something
there are certain things
that
you
you can speak privately
and he can best address
does not cover anything up
you do not want to
seek publicity for something okay that
may set hairs running
and may be inappropriate
and may expose a lack of understanding
they always say before can actually ask
more questions and the wise man can
answer
so i bear that in mind as well
but if i have concerns
i follow them up and i address them
can i then just widen that because i
feel that um under the previous four
years 2015 to 19
we as a council and i include myself
um
[Music]
that was a conservative at the time
there was a major issue that caused the
strengths of 1.253 million pounds
and none of us as counselors actually
asked the question for council
and i'm really concerned that sometimes
we know what the question is that we and
i include myself here
were afraid to ask him and i'm trying to
protect against something happening the
same way again in the future
i'm aware of what you speak of
and
i'm aware that at that time
which is a part two items
i'm not
but i think that correctly okay i think
that the relevant
questions were asked
of the relevant offices
and cancers had a full understanding of
the situation
i i'm going to pass this over to you
is that we as coaches have a
responsibility to raise issues okay and
i feel that looking at history there are
certain times where we've not raised
those issues and i'm trying to put
protections in place for doing a fully
important governance
um
function we've got to be able to ask
those questions so there's a separation
from
the executive
but there has to be good working
relationships
yeah
i've got a
couple of points to make really i i
don't think i think they go hand in hand
i think you can have a good of working
relationship and you still answer that
ask those challenging questions i mean i
think as senior officers we're expecting
to have challenges but you know to us
and to answer those questions and
actually from our perspective if members
are pulling something out that we may
not have seen we want to do that because
i think from george's perspective it's
in everyone's interest that things are
run as they should be
um you know we do get a lot of you
pushing things under the carpet that may
be what i think but but it's not you
know within our our teams
and as council hack said and as council
bushby said actually you know if you
come and have a chat with us we will be
very open and honest with you that the
matter that you're referring to i think
i can count on one hand the members
actually came up and discussed that
matter with me
um
it was a difficult matter a lot of it
was in part two but if they'd come and
chatted to me behind the scenes i could
have been far more open and honest about
the situation
and i think sometimes you're presented
with challenging questions um in a
public meeting that you know you know i
can't necessarily answer especially if
it's a legal matter um if you'd have
come back to me behind the scenes i
would have been able to give you some
answers and some assurances but i have
you know with this this matter ended a
long time ago now um but i you keep
hearing it repeatedly that it you know
questions weren't asked but nobody came
and asked me
why nobody came and asked me
he was a solicitor at the time and i did
leave the independent group at that
point
and i did and jenny hollis
did for me a lot of information and he
was very supportive and did nothing from
me so there was a lot of stuff that
came through behind the scenes um
by talking but it wasn't perceived by
the public and the public you need to
know that we are owning
um
our offers to work and it's not the cash
flow which is out but it is to to be
able to hold to account where
the money has gone to basically
what
i i actually spoke to jamie wise and
stacy
and i asked every question i wanted to
ask him
and got satisfactory answers
so i'm completely satisfied
that we representing the public
were able to get the questions answers
that we
required
whether or not we can transmit
those questions and answers to the
general public on sensitive private
matters
is another matter but they have to have
a degree of
understanding that we are there to
represent them and their best interests
although we cannot
tell them exactly what we're doing
as officers we work for the council um
we follow through decisions that made up
committee
um
you know and as you know all the
decisions most the the large decisions
are made through the committee process
and as officers we are then
directed to follow through those
decisions um i i it really does sadden
me to hear
and people don't want to challenge us or
that we're trying to sweep things under
the carpet because you know from our
perspective you know nothing further
could be you know from the truth
um
and if you pop in or give us a call you
know we'll always very happily and i say
this time and time again come in and see
us and i if it's something that we know
about we we will quite happily and
openly discuss that there might be stuff
that can't go into the public um domain
and and they'll be for different reasons
and we'll tell you why we can't put
you know a legal case that is ongoing
obviously we can't discuss openly in a
in a a full council meeting it's not
something that comes naturally to me to
have to you know close down but that
that's where we are but you know
certainly even now if you've got
questions i'll very happily sit down and
run through any of those questions pop
your head in the office you know we're
all there you know the senior management
team are office based all the time pop
your head in and very happily um because
this is one that keeps coming round and
round and round and you know we do need
to kind of move on forever
thank you for your responses chair thank
you
i take ruth and then thank you i just
wanted to come back on that i mean this
is a matter which
um
i've never heard of anyone being helpful
about
what happened
and i certainly have no assurance that
it won't happen again
because i know nothing about how it
happened
brought against us okay
now
in in some respects you you either pay
out straight away or you defend if you
think you've got a defense so it was
none you know when you say no one was
held to a cow
it wasn't an officer or a councillor's
fault that a claim was brought against
us we can't stop that and it's that sort
of question that that's sorry but we
lost the case which means we have got
they have a case against us which means
we should have addressed that phase
before it came to thought
or
or well i i disagree and and you know we
i don't think this isn't a gender item
for today i think we're going off so
what i would say just to
this on the head
from my
recollection
at the time
we were fully informed in part two
and the counsellors voted which
direction they wanted to take that
matter and i think it's probably best to
let that go there but with that
assurance that the councillors were
informed every step of the way
on the best of advice we could get
things don't work out the way we would
like on occasions
but we were fully informed
we evaluated the risks
and we took the decisions we took
and i think really
that's that's as far as i'm going to let
this one run
i think we've had a good exploration of
it
thank you
right um
i'm going to thank you paul for the the
report you've done
and we julie notes that if you're still
with us
yeah i am so so chad i just say that i
think um what what i'll do now is work
with dave really to capture i suppose
some of the points raised that at this
meeting i i think there's a number of
sort of um i suppose follow-on actions
and perhaps i mean train training is
always i think
relevant
and to refresh um people's understanding
and so on um
and also on the subject actually of
cyber i do i can share um a um a video
from youtube on
the um
it relates to a cyber attack on the
council actually um and how they dealt
with it which i think is very
interesting so i will share that with
committee members um hopefully it won't
frighten you too much but i think it's
just shows shows some of this of um
some of the challenges involved but but
we will i'll work with with david as i
said on uh sort of updating the document
to reflect these these these points in
this meeting
okay
right
okay thank you very much indeed paul
thank you
so we truly note um
that
item item eight the veterans of the
audit committee
[Music]
um
[Music]
we've taken nine so we're going to item
10 which is the going concern report
pages 28
to 35 so back to our section 151 officer
david if you'd like to
do it sorry can i just knit around and
get my ipad turned on again i thought
i'd
okay
i'm not intending to go through the
report line by line i'll just try to
pick up some of the key highlights for
you and take any questions at the end
and this is a report based on the
financial resilience of the council
now this council like every council up
and down the country faces future
uncertainty regarding government funding
we're expecting a spending review which
is during the autumn and the
government's
view of autumn is quite lastic that
could be into december
and it's probably going to be a review
of the business rate retention scheme
which district councils have been
benefited from
we've been highly uh
advertised that new home bonus game will
end at some point there'll be some
replacement for that but we don't really
have any details of that so there's
uncertainty
we've also got um pressures and
uncertainty guidance division of leisure
the ledger contract texas critical under
contract expires at the end of march
2022
and we know that we're going to have to
provide enhanced support
over the medium term for our leisure
providers if you haven't got question
council
that the contract will not be extended
i always thought that was in part two
that that that their contract wasn't
going to be extended do they know that
yes they do they do they couldn't work
because anyone could read these minutes
they can't no they know that we couldn't
work in an exit strategy of our
colleagues for 1610
so
you know identifying assets that we
might want to retain et cetera um two
key lists of staff so we're actually
working with 1610 on an exit strategy
you know all the discussions we've had
at full council about ending the
contract and setting up an natc have
been in part two so that's a bit
concerned when i read that
sorry
thank you sure
yeah we're back to um number 234 you've
got in in redding
my i've had to run out of batteries
there's not anything significant in that
word in
because it is in the process
does that mean that uh it's not good in
the long-term future or
like interpreting something page
2828.
um
report fifth line down
um the council will operate now at the
end they're in red just telling you the
title that's there is no significance to
that
i'm reading
uh things that i shouldn't be reading
here
and check it on the government
anyway we're getting back to the
threshold we've clearly we know we're
gonna have to provide enhanced support
to leisure over the medium term
and clearly we
recognize that we're gonna have to
invest some significant funds in our
leisure facilities
and nobody really knows what the bounce
back will be users people who got used
to perhaps not going to our leisure
facilities and again they're exercising
different methods
and the current
uncertainty is about construction
pricing place everybody's heard about
building inflation and difficulty of
supplies
they're probably almost certainly
there'll be an impact on our existing
capital programme
and just
10
uplift on our current capital programs
about 18 million of it
is construction related that's 1.8
million
the only way we can really probably
bridge that would be increased revenue
contributions from our revenue budgets
to bridge that gap
we'll do a full assessment reassessment
made in redwood in terms of that re-look
at the capital program and provide an
update on that i mean this is
particularly disappointing given that um
we went through quite a bit of pain in
february 2021 in terms of increasing car
parking charges and and waste charges
are
to try and bridge what was at the time
the funding get from the capital program
at that juncture and it looks like now
there's a pressure down the line
so the other key point well we put 1.6
million pounds aside to reserve during
the financial year 2020
21 of which 771 000 was assigned to
support ledger
we've got 1.2 million pounds in the
transitioning government funding reserve
to meet deficits on our revenue budget
going forward
the projected deficit in february 2021
over the lifetime the median term
financial strategy which went up to
2025-26
was 289 000 pounds clearly in that
juncture with all the best knowledge
we've had at that time we've got 1.2
million in research to meet
deficits and we're only forecasting
deficits over that period for 289 000.
clearly since then the world has changed
we've identified we're going to have
more pressures on leisure the
construction price inflation means we'll
probably have to put more into our
capital reserves from our revenue
accounts
but the conclusion i would make is we
are facing a different degree of
financial uncertainty but we start from
a better place than probably the vast
majority of councils in this country in
terms of we start from a basically
balanced position then we're going to
have to take up international finance
projects we have money set aside in
reserves to meet that so compared to
many councils we're in a good position
the full detail of the pressures we face
will unravel
over the next few months and that'll be
part of the budget 10 process that
probably starts in
uh for officer stats now the members
will start with a capital days from
techcov in december and the revenue
reports which go to cnr internal
produced richard paul council in
february and i have to take any
questions
about this job chair
right i'll throw it over to members
well i'm just impressed with the last
line on uh the last page
um
that you were there more confident the
council can meet his obligations in the
foreseeable future
so i'm really pleased to read that i'm
basically saying i don't believe our
mission is section one one four notices
in the foreseeable future which is the
one where i you can set your own
fireworks can just restrict
just on page 31 and can you i lost track
of the isaac jordan's development can
you tell me where we are because we
submitted on june 18th
rightly
i was going to council peninsula when i
did a verbal update on risk that is one
of the items i was going to allude to
okay that's coming
i've just did at the end of the agenda
in part c
generally what happens on social first
okay
and that is one item that i wanted to
update um thank you
no further comments
right so we're now noting that item
and
we're on writing 11 the annual
government statement
1836
yeah um
[Music]
chris dalton's actually an annual lead
right so
the annual government statement that's
um in your part is this hasn't changed
since the draft annual government
statements was presented at the last
committee so we're just seeking formal
improvement on the annual government
statement
right so
has there been no changes
that should be a formality
um
we note the report does it matter
recommendations
yes you did
and i would like it addressed if i may
please i i
could just say um you should say on the
very bottom paragraph of page 49
internal on that's also called
um yes they called in the burden
and i think it was
the covenant but certainly i was very
involved in the outdoor jet ski
launching i made a single corners chair
of external ons along with four others
one who was on c9 that actually approved
it and then changed the position when
they called
which is quite interesting in the timing
of it and certainly i was fundamental
in challenging the maintenance budget in
the play strategy so i would like at
least external mentions because it's not
correct internal may have heard
the recording that it was external that
made the call in and it's not a fair or
accurate report to just say internal
[Music]
fundamentally organization in at least
two of the items on that list and i
would like the uh
the annual government statement change
to reflect that else i can't support it
yeah um
can i just make a yes
that might alleviate councillor
pennington's concern so scrutiny is
scrutiny as a whole i know it does say
make reference to internal and external
but i think we can
display the fears that scrutiny we know
that external
scrutinizes external activities and
internal internal scrutiny so with
regard to the burden
that was internal funding because it was
the
budget obviously going to the burton so
that would be quite right that um that
was um
the outdoor jet ski launching again
yes you're correct but the cooling came
from internal because it was torch
district land so again it was an
internal function no no chair i must
disagree here i made a single person
calling that was accepted it was put in
the report that went back to cnr
i remember talking to councillor ford
who um who wrote the jet ski motion back
in i think august 2020 and i apologize
to him for calling in um the decision
because i thought the two posts that
were being put downs that went out and i
did make that call in in my capacity as
external ons chair so i reiterate that
and i cannot accept your response to
that part of the question
well we can make amendments to say that
internal and external
yes
so if we make that one amendment
okay
okay so
as this is signed off
i haven't signed up if that's the event
internal and external so
subject to that change
are we happy to
both side if you're subject to that
change okay proposal there have a
and actually kick got that first
actually
finished
okay
so all those in favor
that's unanimous
so we will move on
to
item number 12.
the audit findings report 2021 statement
of accounts page 54 to 92 and receive
a report from grant wanton
so hopefully we can
get through to ground quantum yes very
clear chair thanks very much indeed um
good morning councillors so the
the paper you have in front of you today
um gives you the
key findings and conclusions from our
audit of the council's financial
statements um it's really important to
highlight some of the changes that's
been happening within the code of audit
practice over the course of the year
because typically this time of year we
would also be reporting to you um the
detailed outcomes of our work from our
our value for money assessment
um you will see there is some value from
any commentary within the report but
just to
um just to recap on some of the key
changes that have happened effectively
this year um there was a new code of
audit practice that was issued back in
april last year and with that there was
a new uh methodology issued by the
national audit office in terms of the
way that we conduct our work around the
valley for money audit
it's a much broader remit as far as the
assessment is concerned whereas in
previous years it's been very risk-based
based on specific areas of risk that
that we have within the organization
this we're required to give quite a
broad narrative assessment across uh
three core areas looking at your
financial sustainability around
governance and around your arrangements
to ensure economy efficiency and
effectiveness in the use of resources
so in terms of the actual timetable for
the value for money work we have already
started doing some specific work on the
area that we identified in the audit
plan uh which we identified as a
significant risk area around financial
sustainability
but the broader assessment and the
conclusion of that work will be subject
to a separate report so under the new
code of audit practice we now have to
issue to you an auditor's annual report
which captures the final value for money
assessment
and with this being the first year of
that assessment and also recognizing the
neo recognizing with it obviously with
the current challenges um for
authorities working through covid and
has wanted to prioritize the order of
the financial statements the national
office have allowed us a further three
months to conclude the value for money
work so we have to issue our final vfm
conclusions uh within three months of
issuing the opinion on the financial
statements so you will see some uh
commentary on the vfm side of things in
this report based on where we are at the
moment but there will be a further
report to come back to this committee
once that value for money work has been
concluded
as far as the financial statements side
of things this this is the main part of
the narrative that you find in the
report that's in front of you today
so we initially started our audit back
in back in june i've been working very
closely with with david and and
colleagues uh in terms of reviewing the
financial statements uh i'm pleased to
say that the order is nearing completion
we do have a small number of
areas that we are looking to conclude
and i'll invite andy shortly just to
give the committee a
specific position statement as to as to
where we are with those but in summary
um based on the work that we've carried
out so far we issue we plan to issue an
unqualified um uh financial statement
opinion unqualified is clean as far as
the audit opinion is concerned um one of
the areas that we are working to resolve
at the moment relates to a matter that
was highlighted by the council's valuers
so the council commissions a a
specialist valuer to value the
properties of the council and
specifically within their valuation
report they highlighted what we call a
material uncertainty so that they have
some uncertainty around their valuation
specifically
in relation to the valuations of the
council's leisure centers now we're
currently in discussions with your
section 151 officer and also the valuer
to understand the basis of that
uncertainty
and if it is concluded that that is an
appropriate uncertainty to recognize the
council will need to make a further
disclosure in its account around that
uncertainty and we need to refer to it
in our opinion as what we call as an
emphasis of matter paragraph now that's
not a qualification it's just a drawing
the the the stakeholder or the reader's
attention to the fact that this
particular uncertainty exists
um uh i'm making sure we make reference
to that into our in our audit report so
that is the only area that we are still
looking to specifically include that may
impact on some of the wording of the
opinion but it still will remain as an
unqualified audit opinion
um in terms of the key findings that
have come out of the audit you'll see
there's obviously quite a lot of
information that we have to report to
you to meet our obligations under the
autism standards i appreciate that the
report is quite voluminous and can be
quite technical in nature but very happy
to take any questions if if members
would require any sort of clarification
on any of those but fundamentally if you
look at the overall position for the
audits
we've identified a small number of
disclosure amendments to the accounts
and one
one item that officers have chosen not
to adjust which is very trivial in
nature in terms of its value
which you'll see in the appendices to
the report
we've also highlighted three specific
recommendations um covering both the
value for money work that we've
undertaken so far and our financial
statements work um you have um received
formal responses of that from from
offices
um and so that summarizes the overall
position as far as the financial
statements are concerned so generally
speaking as far as the audit i think the
audit has gone uh very well for this
council certainly would like to put on
record my appreciation for david wren
and colleagues for their continued
assistance in in bringing to the the
final few items on the audit um to a
close i'll just pass over very briefly
to andy just to summarize the the
current position on the audit and just
give you through the the key messages on
the vfm work so far and then we'll open
it out to to member questions andy
thanks julie
can you hear me okay
yes got you andy
great thank you
um so yeah as judy said there's just uh
there's a few few items that are set out
at the beginning of the report that that
are outstanding and
um
what one of the key things is about the
the legend of assurance that that we
receive from the devon pension fund
auditors and that completes our
assurances on the on the pension fund
work we're hoping to have that uh in the
in the middle of middle of october um
which which would then allow us to put
us in a position to be able to sign the
opinion we've got um
very quickly because quite importantly
that letter is becoming later and later
um i remember last year we didn't sign
off the accounts until the 23rd of
september
um
i'm concerned that there is this delay
in the pension fund
letter being received
could you account why this is happening
and
is it going to be something that's going
to cause delays next year
chair if i can come on up on that
specifically i can comment on that
because i'm actually the engagement lead
for the devon pension fund so i can
specifically give you an update on on
that um in terms of the the delays um uh
the short answer is the audit was late
starting because of
some some issues arising from an audit
um that the team that's involved with
the pension fund that the audit prior to
that um uh
went on for it for longer than
anticipated due to a number of areas and
so uh the scheduling of the work um
started later than we originally
anticipated it to um that coupled with
the fact that um some of the investments
that are involved in that pension are
quite complex um and there's quite
some some very specific procedures that
we're required to do in terms of getting
assurances around the valuations of
those types of investments so um i i am
meeting with the audit team on a daily
basis we have
some some very clear sort of project
management calls to to make sure that we
are progressing this as quickly as
possible um but um as i said we are
aiming to complete that work by by the
15th of october so
in in terms of giving the committee
assurance about this not reoccurring in
previous uh in in future years um we are
going to take a very different approach
to
um the way that we deliver our pension
funds across the board not just for
devon uh in future so that they are
very specifically prioritized that
doesn't have any um and an intentional
knock-on effect to the um the audits of
those individual uh employers so we
absolutely take on board your comments
chair um and we absolutely will make
sure to improve that position for next
year
okay thank you julie thank you
thanks julie um so the the other
outstanding item is on the property
plant and equipment uh we've actually
completed our existence checks now so
that that element of that work is is
done we've actually had responses from
the valuer in terms of our queries uh
and we just need to kind of go through
that and assess that and write that up
so we've actually got that got that
information now
the the one the one area of follow-up is
that is as judy mentioned earlier is
around this this material uncertainty
and and and we're gonna have to we're
gonna be speaking to the valuer uh
either later this week or early next
week to try and to try and resolve
trying to resolve that matter
in terms of
the
the going concern side of things
obviously julie's already set out the
context the context of this and
in terms of us being able to issue our
audit opinion we need to be able we need
to have completed the work against the
significant risk that we identified
within the audit plan and the commentary
that we've got here on page 73 onwards
is
is the summary of that work and and the
closing of that that risk um
i think
the the narrative here very much
reflects
what david set out as part of his his
going concern
review
um
so there's obviously
we've got this uncertainty and this very
sort of challenging this very
challenging environment uh over the last
year um
but obviously within that the council
have
delivered an under spend
in year now some of that is down to
coveting
additional covered income but also uh
increases in planning fees and things
and and other elements like that um
we've
excuse me um
so
as part of our work we've obviously
we've reviewed the the budget setting
process that underpins this and
obviously the medium-term financial plan
uh and we've reviewed specifically as
part of that work we've reviewed the
the key assumptions
uh and the key items that have fed into
that plan and on on both those counts
we've we've concluded that they were
reasonable
um
going into quarter one quarter the
quarter one of 21 22 um the council are
also forecasting uh an underspend for
the 21 22 22 year at this at this point
in time and again that is reflective of
the the strong
the robust controls and arrangements
that are in place around financial
sustainability within the context of
this overall level of uncertainty and in
terms of fair funding reviews and and
those unknowns
um
there's obviously a
still remains a financial challenge um
there's a there's a revenue financial
challenge there um
and there's a you know progress has been
made towards closing that the
the 390 400k uh budget gap over the
median term albeit that has been done
largely around
on the on the capital side of things but
obviously
as as david said out in in in his
presentation earlier you know that there
are revenue implications to
to capital
um
[Music]
the council are aware of the challenges
around capital have identified those
part of their arrangements and are
actually taking steps towards putting
putting things in place and actually
reviewing the capital program to make
sure that that stays that stays
affordable and the the
there's
a reduced impact on on any kind of kind
of revenue side of things
um
at the bottom end of our
uh commentary on page 75 we talk about
the
um some of the key things that the
council have got going on presents and
big big projects and some some big areas
that are being worked on at the moment
and
again again david's already spoke about
the leisure the leisure contract and
that's you know that's quite a big
that's quite a big area it's a it's an
area of challenge um
it's an area that the council have
perhaps not been involved in before
around setting up
local authority trading companies so
therefore
whilst the arrangement arrangements to
date are in place and obviously um
david's we've raised a recommendation on
this and
we've seen david's response to that
of what the what the council have done
and what the council are planning to do
and it's just a flag that you know
there's lots of local authority trading
companies out there um
and it's just from from our experience
you know it's it's making sure that as
that evolves and as that as that
progresses that the authority continue
to kind of take professional advice
where needed and make sure that the
governance and monetary arrangements
evolve as the arrangement evolved just
just to make sure that there are no no
issues coming out of that
that was all i was going to say chair in
terms of
in terms of the value for money
okay
thank you very much i know the comments
we've got strong and robust
controls in place which reassured our
committee after
the discussion with previously had
earlier on
um
members
ruth penrose okay can i just answer a
question about the trading company
will we still be in charge of
building governance of the trading
company or wouldn't that be
completely separate from us
they'll be completely separate
it's
um so full council have approved the
appointment of the board but the board
will run the the trading company
um audit and governance i suppose uh
what will come in when it comes to
financing the latest of those internal
controls but the decisions will be down
to that separate board yeah when it's
actually open and running
we will have to consolidate our
statements of account to include
the transactions of the local fighter
training company what something's called
group accounts so but in terms of the
actual day to day no that won't be the
responsibility of this committee
check may i also add a supplementary
comment to that i think the other thing
that's really important given that this
committee's just obviously looked at the
annual governance statement is why this
will be absolutely a separate a separate
company uh in terms of its its set up
it's its governance structure and
obviously will will be duty-bound by the
requirements of the companies act
fundamentally the council will be its
parents and so you will have
responsibilities specifically as the
parents company at the parent
organization to that company and so it's
really important that as part of the
considerations of this committee
certainly to inform your annual
governance statement it's really
important that this committee has a role
in terms of seeking assurance around the
adequacy of the governance of that
committee because effectively
the scope of the the ags should also
cover your group entities as well as the
council itself
would you have any recommendations to
make as to how that might be achieved
um so
examples of where we see elsewhere
for other authorities have local
authority trading companies indeed
they do
they do use uh for example uh internal
audits to undertake some specific work
around the governance arrangements so
they're not physically going into the
company itself and and
and doing audits of the company's data
that will be down to the the company's
own appointed external auditor to do
that
um however um certainly the authority
has a responsibility as you know as a
commissioner of services from that
company to make sure that you've got
adequate governance and ready to place
so effectively you know there can be a
review done to look at how the council
as andy said how the council is
monitoring understanding what the
business plans are for that particular
company and how you're holding that
company to account to effectively
deliver services on behalf of the
council so there's absolutely ways in
which you can seek assurance as a
council um in the way that you are
commissioning and working with that that
you know commercial entity um to to
deliver services on on behalf of torrid
so there's absolutely ways in which in
which you can can do that uh to to get
assurance
okay i'll take note of that ruth you
want to tell me and then just come back
on that so if the company went fast
because we as a parent are we
responsible for any death
that effectively will come down to
however the contract is effectively set
up between yourselves and the local
authority trading company as to what um
what you decide to guarantee and what
your risks and exposures are so this is
going back to andy's point it's
absolutely vital that in how you're
setting up um the the this company
that you fully understand as members
what your risks and exposures are
obviously there's lots of benefits of um
of being involved with companies you
know if the companies are delivering
services effectively and realizing the
profits that it plans to under its own
business plans then there's a direct
benefit to the council but it's not it's
really important the audit committee
recognizes that there are absolutely
always risks involved with undertaking
any form of commercial venture and you
have to recognize this is a separate
commercial company that will be set up
um you know subject to companies at
rules etc so it's really important that
you do put those monitoring arrangements
in place and those governance stretches
in place to make sure that you are
getting the assurance you need about how
that company is operating so that
effectively is what has driven our
recommendation that we've put in the
report
thank you ruth sorry just come back
again so if they make a profit who earns
the
profit as i said that will come down to
the specifics of the agreement uh that
the council has set up with the company
you find in some instances um uh because
i think a lot of this is linked to to
legislation as well in terms of for it
to um to to to get any specific tax
benefits as a local authority trading
company um there's certain rules that
you have to fulfill in order to to get
those tax benefits so um i can't give
specifics in terms of this this company
because obviously it's still in its
formation stage but you know some of
some authorities elsewhere you know they
may take a profit share uh but some of
those profits will be reinvested back
into the company to continue to deliver
services on behalf of the authority so
the short answer to your question
council is it it depends on how the
agreement is set up as to what level of
profit you effectively will will will
receive
probably almost being a little bit
premature because in reality what's
going to happen it won't be any profit
it'd be a level of support
it's also how do we build in an
expectation that they start from a low
base
and hopefully i will move to a more
sustainable base
that's wrong this is about giving this
yeah i was just trying to understand the
ownership of the trading company and how
it affects us
but i i take the point that we need to
look very very carefully at the contract
when we're setting it up
i think that we'll go through
i think that's
going to be a very
good point
rose
um lines of query on right london's
invoice i mean i'm new to the community
so i don't know whether their non-audit
fees comes up every year but what do
they do for nearly 20 thousand pounds
for the certificate certification of
housing benefits today i'm glad i'm not
going to answer that question
quite extensively but um julie over to
you on that yeah chair very happy to
answer the question um so we we don't we
don't get to determine the level of
testing that we do in this area so
there's a very specific methodology that
we're required to follow under the
department for working pensions
um housing benefits assurance process
methodology so we are required to set uh
to undertake
a number of checks on the housing
benefit return that the authority
prepares that goes into the dwp so
there's some general checks and general
reconciliation checks and casting checks
and making sure it it agrees to the
underlying housing benefit system of the
authority but then in addition to that
there's specific sample tests that we
have to carry out on individual claims
for the different expenditure types of
housing benefit that the the authority
um uh provides um so effectively um the
level of testing can change from one
year to another and that is
fundamentally down to the level of error
rate that's identified during the course
of that test and so if you if if we do
our standard testing which is 20 items
per benefit type which is what the dw
requires us to undertake if you did if
we did a sample of 20 and and found no
issues
then there's no extended testing to
carry out however if there was an error
identified under the methodology we then
have to go into what we call 40 plus
testing which effectively says for the
attribute that has failed you have to do
a further 40 cases
to um to test specifically on that
attribute um whether that error is
isolated or it's something you need to
extrapolate over the whole population of
claimants that are entitled to that
element of benefit and then we're
required to prepare a detailed report to
the dwp on all the results of that so
that they can then determine what impact
that will have on the amount of subsidy
payable to the authority so it's quite a
prescribed methodology it's not like the
main audit where it's it's much more
judgmental in terms of external orders
taking a view on what's levels of
materiality and which items are risk
based that we you know focus our test in
this is quite prescribed in terms of the
level of sampling that we need to do
each year
so can i just come back on that there's
the next year could you as um
builders choose a different um non-audit
path to go down to
go down or would this come up again
so um it comes down to the authority's
decision because it's outside of the psa
contract the council is not under any
duty to appoint grant thornton to do the
housing benefits it used to be part of
the main audit contract um a couple of
years ago before we went out to the psa
framework contract for appointing
auditors so uh effectively your
authority has come to us uh previously
for for a quote to deliver those
services um we have delivered those
under under a contract up until the
current year and we're currently in
discussions with david about um whether
he seeks to um uh to to to for us to put
a new contract in place for next year or
whether um uh whether he intends to go
out to the market so that's that's
purely down to the authority to decide
well how they want to appoint
for housing benefit that's not in any
way shape or form uh
attached to the main responsibility you
have under under accounts however
because it's a separate audit related
service that we carry out on behalf of
the council alongside our audit of the
financial statements we're required
under the ethical standards to report
that that additional work to you as
non-audit services
the one thing i've raised in previous
years of charges that suddenly appear
there's a likelihood that we're going to
get additional charges they should be
brought up
forward at the time rather than
later on
um
we have to formally
approve the statement of accounts i'm
happy to recommend that
we've got some questions
okay just um the question on page 64.
um
and certain pages where you've got the
light purple on the right hand side and
i then see the bullet point in the
bottom in very very small print
because i have to magnify
but
i can't magnify anything i don't know
why but
i think i can just read it but there is
a discrepancy between what has been
reported and what actually
can you explain that please
sorry council i can just repeat which
page it was 64 did you say
look at the 64 on the left-hand side of
the page and it's now in
landscape form
and then there's a bar on the right hand
side of the page that says like turkey
to the assessment right at the bottom of
the page
and i'm trying to magnify and i don't
know why i can't magnify it before but
um
because of the wording that was there
sure okay and so we've
assessed it as light purple because
based on the work that we've carried out
so far around
um the review of the um
the valuers work on his asset valuations
we haven't identified any specific
concerns the reason why it's not
anything other than light purple at the
moment is going back to what i was
saying at the start was at the moment we
haven't formally concluded on the issue
around the material uncertainty because
we're trying to understand the basis in
which the valuer has made that
conclusion so at the moment we're saying
there's nothing
in our view that raises concerns around
management's current assumptions we are
really at the moment making further
enquiries
to understand the base in which the
valuer has made that sort of material
uncertainty conclusion so if there's
something that if
once those inquiries have been concluded
actually the evidence that the valuer
presents to us doesn't coincide with the
conclusion he gave in his report
we may need to change the color of that
assessment but based on the work carried
out to date um we we're not concerned
that management's assumptions are not
appropriate so that's why we've put it
currently as light purple
joshua pennington have ages to attach a
flame
so basically what the different value
has said is that there's material
uncertainty regarding the valuation of
leisure facilities okay
now i would assume the event
future leisure income
you know as an asset you would say
that's worth less because maybe people
are going to less go to legislators
it seems
to the management slightly erroneous
statement to make when in our accounts
our leisure facilities are valued in
what's called drc which is direct
replacement cost
so we have our legislativities costed at
the cost they would be to rebuild them
so that doesn't take into account any
income that they actually generate
so to say there's uncertainty about
leisure income
don't necessarily disagree in our books
the assets are valid in just the cost of
replacing them to physically rebuild
them that seems separate from any income
related matters you know like say the
town hall
is our direct replacement that's never
generated
so that's where we're waiting for
because it may be that the different
values put that statement in because
for example our car parks evaluation of
our car park is based on the they
generate
not on how much it costs to retire
um it was described as the parent the
council is described as the parent
that would imply the iatc as a child
and given my parenting skills they've
not been doing years
who has the responsibility of actually
putting the agreement together is it for
council or is it the lapc board of
maryland place sending their agreement
back council to ratify which way around
is it
well that part of the reason why we had
the leisure workshop was for members to
say
what they want in the specification and
as a result of that that workshop that
happened david rushton is putting
forward a specification so i can
incorporate that into a contract but
ultimately that's coming back to full
council and there will invariably be
some tweaking but it's the same with the
business plan so we're waiting to put
the business plan together
um so that that can bomb part of the
contract as to what their reporting
requirements will be
what their kpis will be
what funding we're going to provide that
company so there's all that sort of
stuff but no ultimately it's going to be
a contract that tourists are happy with
in terms of
rights and responsibilities for what
they've got to do
but it's going to be balanced with the
fact that they need to be commercial and
obviously try and um
obtain an income going forward so that
they're less reliant upon charge
subsidizing sure
latc sends the contract for the full
council to ratify no tolerance will
draft the contract and that will come to
full council for blockchains into
discussions yeah
but into the contract
yeah and lastly very briefly
every page has got commercial and
confidence a small print on top this is
part two stuff that's commercial
incompetence and little little print
right at the top of the page
is this incompetence is it under part
two or what is commercial incompetence
applying to this
report yeah there's a it's a great
question through your chair this this is
just a a stamp that goes on so this is
all grand thornton documentation so this
is not commercial and confidence as far
as
uh not being accessible or able to be
seen by anyone in the public this is
just uh in terms of how we designate and
classify our own documentation um
fundamentally this report is for the
authority um in terms of your your use
and it's just the way that we um we have
different designations between um you
know sort of uh
personal male versus uh internal versus
anything sort of client related will
either be commercial in confidence or um
highly confidential so it'll have
different designations so commercial and
confidence doesn't have any you know
part two implications as far as your
reporting is concerned if it was marked
highly confidential then it probably
would be so yeah just to clarify that
but but sorry for any confusion as far
as that's concerned that's just a grand
thoughts and internal designation of our
documents
thanks to the question
how does grant portland won a local
authority department that would look
better at local authorities because
we're not a commercial organization we
are authority organization
do you have any comment on that
forgive me so i didn't quite hear the
full question it was a little bit quiet
from our side
so you're referring julie i think to
the fact that that is part of the arm of
grant fulton if i heard that correctly
all i'm saying is that that we are not a
commercial organization we are a local
authority organization and i'm just
asking is grant portland not got a
pacific local authority auditing
function rather than a commercial or a
auditing volunteer
yeah so granthan has got a very specific
um public sector audit team so
commercial
as i said this is terminology i
appreciate but commercial in the context
of the the language that we use on on
the corner of this report is not as in a
commercial entity it has a sort of
different definition from our internal
point of view um so yeah as i said it i
do apologize if there's any confusion
but um just to reassure the committee
um that there's no specific concerns
from it from a confidential point
confidentiality point of view here
we don't have specific designations by
sector it's just trying to to recognize
those that are client facing documents
versus those are highly confidential
documents versus those that are internal
so it's it's just given designation as
far as that's concerned
thank you
expected or anticipated fees of around
70 73 000 pounds for the uh
[Music]
basically pretty much every local
authority was part of the tender it's a
public sector audit appointment board
that coordinated it
so that we had a price
at that point then subsequent to that
there's been additional pieces of work
which um
demanded by the financial reporting
council i essentially the governing body
of order said you need to do a greater
level of deeds and generally what
happens is
something happens in the commercial
sector where a black hole is found
and the people look and think hang on
was the orders as robust as it should
have been
and the bar gets raised when the bar
gets raised
that becomes increased cost to us
there's some additional money being
allocated from central government for
the increased audit costs that we've
experienced since the start of this
contract
and they work i think about 15 000
pounds to us
they won't match
they'll come up a little bit short on
the actual cost so we've even been
honest with you that was they're just
costs that the council's had to have
sold
so
i don't have a right to the section one
five one officer simply saying
um i don't want to be audited please i
don't have that right but we made
representations to psa saying we don't
believe that the fees were being charged
by grandfather
are justifiable but ultimately for the
public sector or the appointment board
to say whether they are or not and then
when we're instructed to
you know being honest we have to take
our
punishment so we don't have an option of
using any other company i'm not in the
current contract
no not in the current country
the other thing to know is actually the
actual market for public sector audience
it's a very very limited market i did
explore with colleagues
across depth whether there was any
appetite across devon to go out
next time to tender just for ourselves
rather than involved in the public
sector
and to be honest there was no appetite
this one was about timing issues in
terms of the colleagues of county which
would be the biggest
player in the consortium so to speak
to comment specifically in terms of our
presence in the market i think it's
really important as david was sort of
alluding to that um you know
auditors that are required to undertake
public public sector audit work um are
very different to those who undertake
order in a commercial sector so under
the local audit and accountability act
um
people like myself who are the
engagement leaders that sign off these
audits we have to go through specific uh
regulatory um sign off and approval
through the icaw to become what we call
a key audit partner so that's a very
specific designation to say that you are
experienced within public sector so we
can't just appoint any specific um
individual to a public sector that they
have to have a certain level of
experience specialism specifically
within our sector and so going back to
david's point about the sort of players
in the market this is about individual
audit firms being able to demonstrate
that they have the skills and also the
capacity of public sector specialists to
be able to carry out that work under
this under the contract and i think
that's really where some of the
challenges have been around some of the
delivery wider in the market at the
moment is that there is a finite amount
resource in in in public sector audit
specialism
nationally to be able to conduct the
level of work that is now required now
that bar is continuing to be raised by
the regulator so it's an area within the
market that we're all continuing to sort
of grapple with but that but that
fundamentally is is is the position
where the contract is concerned now psa
is part of its latest contract round are
trying to look at ways to
try and introduce much smaller firms
into the market whether that be them
working on uh contracts on a more
collaborative basis or partnering up
with some of the firms like ourselves
and others that have the specialist
capacity already in place
and that's some of the different options
they've been looking at as part of their
um contract consultation um over over
the last couple of a couple of months
but it's really just to give assurance
to this committee
that all of the fees that are presented
this to this committee have to go to psa
for consideration approval we can only
propose but we do not determine the fee
for this authority um if psaa are not
comfortable that that level of work has
been warranted by the fee that we are
proposing and indeed they have rejected
um approvals uh of fees and variations
of fees in the past so i don't want to
give this committee impression they just
send everything through with a nod they
absolutely do speak to individual
authorities um to listen to their
concerns and indeed if they need to
we'll do spot checks and audit files to
make sure that the level of additional
work is justified where a fee variation
is required so hopefully that gives the
committee some assurance that this isn't
just a number we're sort of plucking out
of there there's actually a formal
process that goes around um that the fee
the fee variation exercise
[Music]
one or two years to go
if we went out to tender individually
that's quite an expensive
exercise to do
so what we i would intend to do we
haven't made this decision yet but when
the next we've got to buy the eight foot
margin i think it's probably something
we should put on the next committee
meeting we'll look at the forward plan
the
psaa will do another exercise and go out
to tender so that'd be
to be honest virtually every council in
the country that's currently got
external audit going through the psa
um
contract procurement process and that's
due for renewal
i think not next year of the year after
all we've got to show
a commitment where we want to be part of
that bigger process
um by march of 2022 and one of the
reasons one would want to do that is
they do all the specification of the
work that needs to be done to do that
alone
would be challenging and you probably
wouldn't get the benefits of
the group discount really being honest i
i don't want to i don't know because
there's grandparents here
when they put their price in something
will be
the biggest chunk they get the better
price that everyday could that provide
well it's quite interesting because
outside my life at torres on clark and
his multiple finance clubs are happy
i know it doesn't compare in any way
whatsoever with the you know about the
money going through the hands but we
always used to be with grandfathered up
to two years ago
and then nothing to do with the capital
decision we would take it away from
grant ford and put with pkf little
john's
so i don't know whether they could do
this
yes council and just to answer your
question specifically on your town
council again that was subject to a
separate framework contract so your
transition from grand thornton to pkf
was was again part of a a larger um
procurement exercise that effectively uh
we were one of the suppliers to uh town
community councils
until the end of the last contract uh
and then did didn't continue within
within the the new contract so um that's
why you've now moved to pkf it wasn't
through an appointment well it wasn't
through an appointment process where
you've ended individually appointed it
was because the the contract suppliers
effectively that were appointed to to
that element of the audit work had
changed so
very similar circumstances all be a much
smaller scale
is one of the um risks
in
delivering the audit on time has been
the lack of audit staff it's been
highlighted by the psaa
how is that being
addressed at the moment are you managing
to recruit more staff that would allow
your to be
done in a more timely manner and i know
it's something industry-wise across the
board but how things sitting with um
yourselves at grand thornton
yes yes so it's been a combination of
factors we as a firm in fact we were
having a
a a
firm update um only yesterday in terms
of
where we are with this and and there's
been a considerable amount of investment
um put into additional staff this year
and that's a combination of um
new uh new graduate recruitment um some
experienced higher recruitment albeit
that is the element of the market that
is is more challenging at the moment is
trying to get qualified staff uh in
place so we're effectively we're
bringing in more at the graduate level
and trying to grow our own
uh but also we've been um using um some
much wider support within our
international grant thornton network as
well so that we've been using um
additional resource from some of our
overseas firms to also help us uh which
has proved uh very successful um in a
lot of cases so we're looking at
different um
some more innovative ways in which we
can build capacity um within the team so
we absolutely have uh invested um
well over two million pounds in terms of
additional staff cost just in the
current year to to support the delivery
of our of our contract so
um so
so the level of delivery at the moment
has been challenging um i think part of
that is to do with the fact that still
quite a lot of audits are still being
managed remotely
and so you kind of lose some of that
efficiency of everybody sort of sitting
in a room and all working together as as
one team and we really hope that we can
start to transition out of that more so
now now the the the covered restrictions
are obviously starting to be lifted
um but also um i think the other aspect
is more the regulatory aspect as well in
terms of uh meeting our our regulator
and our quality um requirements to make
sure that we are delivering not only um
a timely audit but one to a level that
that you can seek assurance from and
also meet the expectations of our of our
regulators so it's a very difficult
balancing act to balance quality and
speed um but obviously reputationally
it's really really important for us that
we meet our quality standards uh because
absolutely this committee would be
holding me to account if if we're not if
we're not delivering uh the level of
quality we should be delivering as far
as our audits are concerned so um
absolutely we are responding to the the
um the resourcing side of things um but
it's a continuous journey as i said
because we're having to build a lot of
it from the from the bottom up so it
will take a little bit of time to to get
us back to the optimum level but it's
we're certainly making some some big
strides this year
thank you so timely effective and robust
we're looking forward and thank you for
that assurance so um
we now move on from um
that update uh on the ags
and
um
sorry
the audit finding report so now we
formally
you're going to do a quick presentation
number 13 for the approval of the 2021
financial statement of the presentation
it's just a fairly young presentation
okay so
so what would the key highlight from the
draft audio accounts that were presented
at the previous committee world we said
1.6 million we set aside into reserves
over the budgeted transfers
as a result of surplus as we obtained
the pension fund deficit have moved
adversity by 10 million pounds
reflection assumptions about future
inflation
earmarks reserves increased to 15.7
million for an 8.9 million however
3.9 million have been set aside to meet
totally to show the
death the loss of the nmdr collection
from the business rate collection fund
and just point eight of a million was
set aside we've just better government
grants that we've received in advance so
went to reserve because we've had money
in advance of actually using it
it was a rising in short-term creditors
from 12.6 million from from 3.4 million
but that just reflects business support
grants received from central government
which we have distributed
there's a rise in short-term debtors so
8.99 2.9 million reflecting that central
government demo council by authority
over tolerance council money for income
business rate income which were paid
over based on budget rather than the
actuals
and there was 41.7 million of
expenditures in income which was
completely excluded from the state
accounts and greater business of
programs where the council
simply is acting as an agent of
government so the good news is in terms
of the
final statement of accounts nothing's
changed all those are true so the key
highlights i went through at the last
meeting there's been no fundamental
change got the next slide please don't
um so what has changed some minor typos
probably most of them mine
and there's some additional emphasis on
points of clarity in the narratives on
page nine the capital expansion
narrative added an explanation of the
main reasons that slipped on the capital
programme was a fail to deliver an
environmental center so before it just
shows slippage you didn't give the
explanation of the slippage
page 16 was revised to include a
statement projected balance on the
transaction transaction transition in
government funding reserve by 2025 to
26. so they're just little points of
emphasis in the narrative so
fundamentally other than typos the
narrative would the narrative remain
unchanged next slide please tom
so what did change well we don't need to
do what's called um trading operations
accounts anymore
so we showed what was there before and
we didn't fill in the box for 2021
because we were established to do it our
audit colleagues didn't really like
that's what we did we put both
1920 and 2021 even though there's an
obligation to joel 2021 next year this
entire note won't be there just a minor
change next slide please
um
and we added a note at the bottom of
note 18 detailing the council's
appreciation policy so we didn't have
anything that actually said
how long we depreciate a vehicle over or
property
uh another asset so we just added a note
just so that um
the reader of the council wouldn't know
that next slide please tom
um
we had an additional
narrative at the bottom of the assets
held for sale to actually include the
london cleave board but actually before
it said the site that brings with war
from the world would be agreed subject
to completion actually missed out to
mention with the assets helped out the
biggest item would actually cleave would
not run for what next slide please tom
um as we've alluded to we had to update
for the actual audience fee
um just a little bit discrepancy what we
understood from our records the other
fee wasn't what our colleagues at
grandfather said the order fear so we've
amended the rdp that is one of the top
ones but one of the bothers to change so
like i said no real change there next
slide please tom
and that's it
so what i'm trying to um just by that
brief run through is saying i'm i'm
actually quite proud of the team that
worked for me there was so little
changes to the stainless account i mean
this temperature
i mean maybe over 100 pages now 220
pages
and the audit that i called the
grandfather gave a certain
i'll say that
and despite all that other than probably
titanfall in me and the narrative the
changes were very few
so we could
i want to ask julia question at this
point
the recommendation is that we approve
the accounts
is it possible to do a recommendation to
approve and subsequently sign the
accounts if there's no changes arising
from subsequent changes um recommended
to the accounts
yeah so
um again we have the situation quite
often so you're absolutely fine to um to
recommend for approval um uh all i would
suggest is that the committee also gives
um any any delegated authority to you
david that should anything arise from
you know our subsequent discussions with
the valuer that need any sort of
modification
to the final words in that you're
obviously given the ability to be able
to change that and what we can do is is
is coordinate with you a a subsequent
email round to all committee members so
they're at least cited if there's any
subsequent amendment that's that's going
to be uh needed as a result of that
okay so it's okay to go straight to a
recommendation that we approve the count
subject to any
late alterations which will be
circulated to members and it's delegated
to myself and council hackett yeah as
long as the chair is comfortable with
that
i'm comfortable
thank you very much julie your work and
your staffs work on doing the audit and
also david
for a first-class set of accounts that
have been produced and the work you and
your staff have undertaken
in what has been a very very difficult
year
and i think that the committee would
like to
to send those words back to your team
okay so much appreciated
but we appreciate the work you do
so
if i could make that formal
recommendation to be
written in
so i'm composing that from the chair if
i could have a second rose you were
first there
and all those in favor unanimous
thank you very much indeed thank you
um we will now
move on to the
we're on the left letterhold
representation next which is item 14
pages 101 to 105.
would you like me to introduce this
david
please um
sure um so chair this this is a letter
that comes to the um order committee um
every year at the conclusion of the
audit and it's effectively what we call
a management representation letter so
this is david uh signed on behalf of
management uh and also the audit
committee to say that you have provided
all necessary information to us during
the conduct of our audit that we need to
be aware of in being able to form a
conclusion on the accounts so um it
talks about some of the specific
information requirements you've
disclosed to us any non-compliance with
things like laws and regulations you've
disclosed to us any issues that you have
around fraud
um you've disclosed to us any uh ongoing
legal uh cases that you know we need to
be aware of in case there's any sort of
provision that needs to be made into the
accounts and that you're satisfied with
the accounting policies and obviously
the key estimates that management have
prepared the account under so it's
effectively just confirming back to us
that you've you've um you've met all of
those specific responsibilities so um i
open it out to to to the committee for
any specific questions or clarification
uh otherwise it it's it's ready to be to
be signed here we will um at the
conclusion our audits on on the physical
day that i sign the opinion i do ask
both david and the the audit um the
audit committee chair just to confirm
that there's no been no changes or
updates to this letter at the point i
signed the opinion but for the purposes
of this committee um they can they can
recommend for signature
that's straightforward enough
to load that item
i recommend to see the chat
okay so all those in favor of
recommendation for signature
i'll take a photo of myself a second
from
councillor pennington is nodding others
in favor
unanimous
thank you very much
thank you julie thank you andy and we
now move on to item 15
page 106 which is the forward plan
i made a comment earlier about the
meeting at the beginning rather than the
end
in the notes um
we spoke earlier about
our january
meeting that we have something about
cyber security
are you incorporated over in the draft
audit plan maybe move that discussion
sooner
okay right
so remain as it is and we know that item
okay thank you
right we now
go to item 16 exclusion the public the
chair to move publicly excluded from the
remainder of the meeting because of the
likely disclosure of exempt information
by virtue paragraph 3 part 1 in
paragraph 10
part 2 schedule 12 a local government
act 1972
so
i'm proposing for the chair i'm looking
for seconder
ruth second all those in favor
right
items